so I just want to give you a little
history now you you have a heart problem
you have a calcified erratic arch right
here and not much
okay those and then I think did they
diagnosed you with something a certain
thing or um he likes to gnosis okay and
then they wanted to do a remove replace
the a or arch and then replace the
aortic valve and the mitral valve and
two bad passes okay
another method you want to do anything
that's all little overlap then I told
her I said we have some spare parts in
the back but she didn't want to do that
now I'm just kidding
so you you this some of the symptoms
that you had or before you came or what
well I could I mean I didn't breathe
very well I would you know take short
breaths thanks today I'm breathing much
better I don't feel every breath I take
totally and then you have a good asthma
yes I have asthma so I was wheezing a
couple of days ago and then you also had
sleeping problems
yes really would I sleep more than three
hours at a time
and then you also climbing stairs wasn't
the best thing right I you know I could
barely make it upstairs so basically we
we worked on the adrenal acupressure
points and and just kind of tell me how
you slept well the the last night will
say last night I went to sleep around
eleven and I didn't wake up until about
six and we went to the restroom and then
I went right back to sleep and woke up
at 8:30 but you know I can fall asleep
Wow
then you're you're breathing better yes
I'm breathing oxygen is good and then
you feel more relaxed yes I feel not
more
relax then I did it first and it's been
maybe a couple days or so - Friday was
the first day I got that treatment it's
Monday so that's one two three days and
then also you even you're you're losing
weight already I believe so we didn't
but it my stomach is flatter then
therefore that's a good benefit and then
also you see when I was watching her
chest breather when I was working on her
the whole chest was trembling I mean you
can just see a trembling and because the
heart was was working so hard and
everything is so quiet now and you're
not gasping for air which is really good
yeah good so and then so you feel more
hopeful I feel a lot more hopeful great
hope I feel there is hope now awesome
yeah okay well thank you very much sure